i don't think i've ever seen a hybrid
panel discussion so let's see how this
will work
so would it be possible to have the
panelists the speakers up all of the
pictures or is that difficult
hey i see con that's great
and i know elias is there i see him as
well and we're okay perfect and
frederick is here in front of us okay
that already looks like a real panel
um oh no i see them but oh yeah perfect
yay good great
okay
um you should take a microphone yes
and i will be running around i mean they
should hear you guys if you're talking
but it might be better or i can also
repeat the question and i'll try to run
around as well
okay so with this um let's just get
started so i want to first just open it
up for everyone um if there were
questions to any of the speakers
and then also of course if there are
questions like more general um so let's
get started over here and i'll be
running
so this quest question is for the first
stop
frederick
um so there were a sequence of measures
by information theorists called hyper
contractivity measures so if you look at
them one way of looking at it is through
the information bottleneck principle so
if you have two variables x and y
you can course grain x into u
and you
look at maximizing the mutual
information between
the coarse grained u and y
divided by the mutual information
between
the course grain and x
the division is important
and it turns out it satisfies
what is called rainey's
axioms so there were five or six axioms
that rene proposed long ago for the
for an unnormalized sorry normalized
correlation measure and it turns out it
also has some directional properties
so i was just wondering
why go with the mutual information
because it's known to be an unnormalized
measure so what do i mean by that if you
reduce noise
between x and y gradually
essentially what happens in continuous
spaces the mutual information blows up
so it's not normalized between zero and
one
so between two situations you don't
really know whether this effect is more
compared to another effect or not
but if you look at these rainy
correlation based measures
hyper contractivity is one uh it
basically normalizes the measure so i
was wondering when your co-screening
does such considerations played
important role have you looked at any of
these alternate measures from
information
so i don't know those measures so i
would have to have a look at this but
remember i was not presenting my story
on this i was uh criticizing another one
that used mutual information so
um
i
i don't have anything to say about those
other measures
and
i think the reason for using mutual
information in
this case is only because of the
connection to channel capacity
but
as i try to indicate in my talk i don't
think it's the right way to go so
i
take your
your references as an encouragement to
look somewhere else
hi um firstly thank you
hello
um
firstly thank you all for some very nice
talks uh i had a
question for the last speaker uri
um
so
you give this distinction between
offline data where you observe a partial
part of that vector x and online data we
observe the full vector x
i was trying to think of if you could
help give me some
intuition for when that will show up
because presumably
offline data is collected from previous
online trajectories so when
how how does such asymmetry show up
in the real world
um so two examples
i actually have three examples one if if
the online if the offline data is from
humans
humans just perceived differently than
machines uh they didn't see exactly what
the
automatic driver sees
that's one a second might be privacy
concerns you might have demographic data
or sensitive data that you may not use
a third which is surprising but turns
out to be true at least from my
discussions with people for example at
google they run contextual bandits or
things that are like complicated
versions of contextual bandits
and so essentially they should have all
of x right because they ran it in the
his in you know last year they ran it so
they should have all the data they do
not necessarily have holiday
they might not have the entire x or the
policy
and that was used historically in their
own setting it turns out it's a much
more complicated problem than we in
academia might have appreciated
questions
so follow up to that question uh so you
considered a case where in the offline
part the context the part of the context
is not observable but in the online case
that part is actually observable so my
question is is there an example where it
would make sense to have in both cases
that part being not observable
like even in the online case the context
that influenced your reward is still not
available for the online agent
um
yeah and it could have been available to
the offline one yeah uh that's yeah that
could be so it
so online it will not affect our actions
right but it might stuff like the reward
and the transition yeah and yes that is
an interesting scenario that we have not
yet looked into
so maybe i'll i'll ask also something
for um kuhn nanda leos in both of your
talks of course kunha you had like some
you know if you make some very weak
parametric assumptions you're telling us
how much more you can actually learn
elias you're taking a completely
non-parametric approach
um so what you know where would you see
like a middle ground between the two and
how much more could actually be said
maybe also for these transport formulas
if you're taking a slightly parametric
approach like maybe ruling out some
distributions
for any of you
oh okay
thank you very much carolyn uh
yes give me a minute so uh basically uh
you can see i also consider non-profit
completely non-parametric case uh it's
because in many situations actually the
information in the data is strong enough
so that you can just drop the parametric
assumptions fountains in time series
right let's consider classical scenario
if you consider if you want to ultimate
time delay correlations um from time
series then clearly right it's nothing
but
dependence
from depending you can immediately find
a representation so in many cases it
will have such side information so that
we can completely recover the
representation without making use of
parameter assumptions however
if you do not have time information or
distribution shift information very
often time that we can benefit from the
additional assumptions which imply
the independent changing condition or
which implies the identifiability
because of the independent chinese
property and i believe
that
um
i should stop here elias you go first
you went first but thanks
hey quan
the taker caroline for your question i
want just to make a comment about the
the previous one uh i don't know who
asked that it was kartik it sounds like
his voice but yeah of course we can have
uh experimental data uh in which you
don't have some if i understood
correctly that you don't observe some
covariance any any two robots that have
different set of sensors they may do it
maybe they may be doing experiments in
the environment and they have access to
a different set of coverage and may be
affected even by this set of coverage
and i think it's a natural scenario kind
of very interesting
now about caroline's uh question about
the maybe the tension between parametric
and
non-parametric uh i think my feeling is
like i always would try to i think as a
spectrum right and i always try to start
from the non-parametric side given that
this last commutal
and uh anyone may be introducing less of
our own biases or beliefs that may be
wrong and then if you get a negative
result in terms of identification or
learning of the causal diagram or
identification or a transport formula
then maybe you can kind of keep moving
in the spectrum and
and see what assumptions could be
sensible and and see if you can get
identification
identifiability but yeah thanks for the
question caroline
thanks to both of you
let me maybe ask again maybe more and
please also feel free to raise your hand
and dominic will be going around um
maybe for um frederick and um
um and of course kuhn right you both had
about causal representation learning
very different kinds of talks and i
think i asked it at the end and you know
i think also kuhn's example he mentioned
one about the questionnaires and about
the
state of mind or something which would
be overarching variable which might be
slightly different than a coarsening um
but still in the coarsening you also
don't have somehow because there you
don't really have directed edges right
you have these constituent relationships
but how in which cases would the two be
similar um and also how would the two
assumptions that you make one is a
minimality assumption and one is which
are criticizing but still is an
assumption this effective uh this
maximizing effective information when
would they somehow lead to similar kinds
of latent causal variables and when
would be they be very different
frederick points to kuhn so and phone
points back to frederick so you guys
figure it out
do you want to start i want to listen to
barry so frederick please i would like
to listen to you
well
i might be the source of the feedback so
i'm just warning
with it but it seems to be okay now um
so i think the difference of the kind of
setup that i was looking at uh to the
one that kuhn was looking at is that um
there are causal relations from the
macro variables or from the latent
variables in
case two indicators that we actually
measure whereas the setting that i was
looking at was that the the
macro variable was constitutive of the
uh the measurements that we have or was
was a direct function of it it was not
that the pixel values were caused by
um the underlying phenomenon that that
uh
they were constitutive of the underlying
phenomenon so um now we have to ask
ourselves i think both of those settings
are very reasonable settings in
psychometric circumstances like the
example that kuhn was giving um we have
questionnaires and there it seems that
the kinds of questions that uh
subjects are be answering
are indicators that are causal effects
perhaps of some underlying mental state
of depression or anxiety or of whatever
the ones were in in kun setting
whereas in cases where we want to say
it's a feature of an image such that you
recognize a face then it seems like the
pixel values are constitutive of the the
uh face that's in the image right and so
now the question is where where do we
use uh each of these and i think it will
depend on the different settings
which one is appropriate and where they
can um both be applied so now the
caroline's question about
when do they give despite their
different nature quite different
sorry is very similar results
um i think that's quite hard to to say
precisely um
my guess would be
to to look at cases where of course the
causal relations then look very much
like constitutive relations so in
particular if the cause of relations in
kuns setting become very close to
deterministic or something like that
then that is certainly a case where i
think that it doesn't really matter uh
which one of those uh approaches we use
but i actually think this is a really
good question and i don't know a general
answer for it could
what do you think
thank you very much so i have uh i agree
with um
everything you just said let me just
quickly add two points first of all
um
from my perspective i would like to find
the hidden column variables right
according to the formulation so and the
second or however by the way here we
would like to distinguish between causal
representation learning and some um
and another
uh set of approaches trying to
find the compact compact representation
of the call relations right you want to
find a collection of variable functional
collection variables so that you can
have a simpler
description of the relations
and this is the one difference and the
second one is that
although we have the causal latent cause
of variables we have called picture in
practice we have to do inference right
and the inference procedure basically is
trying to derive a function of the
method variables
to capture the information of a latent
variable and now you can see if you care
about the inference procedure or if you
focus on the infinite procedure then the
two things will basically convert in
some way and that's also the reason why
in some situation it's really hard to
distinguish between the two settings
okay uh i'll stop here thank you very
much to both of you
thank you
there are questions in the audience they
will be asked now
this is a question for [ __ ] uh so
there's this existing literature on
identifiable vaes that relies on uh this
auxiliary information that's often given
by some temporally ordered data i was
wondering if you just tell us a little
bit about uh like comparing and
contrasting your approaches to that
existing literature and how they might
be related to each other
oh that's a great question so first of
all actually identifiable va is just an
extension of non-me ica method i
mentioned
right
so this by incorporating a noise right
you can just have the vie framework
but still the underlying independent
variables or the latent variables latent
representation are identifiable so the
first thing is basically it will mention
in my talk it's fundamental and the
second world in many cases uh
we cannot find the independent variables
latent variables remember the last
scenario we consider suppose
what we observe the x i's right the main
variables were generated by latent
variables with chickening called
relations
right z1 causes z2 but this called
influence may change across domains all
the time in this case we can never apply
a fixed transformation to the measured
variables to produce independent
variables
in this case you have to find the
causally disentangled latent variables
with the code relations in order to
recover the truth to make sure that all
what you recover is consistent with the
ground with the code process so the
short answer is that in some cases yes
identify with vie or the original
version of nalini rca would be very
useful but in some situations uh you can
see that you have to go beyond that
because you have to incorporate the
color interactions especially time
changing color interactions
among the latent variables
is the answer to your question
yes
also please all the panelists feel free
to add of course always to any of these
questions otherwise i see another
question there
i i had a question about the first
i had a question about the first talk
um
so you mentioned it was a critique of
this uh this uh work on finding the
right questioning
what do you think is the like key
pro like do you think the goal is the
thing that's impossible and would you
like no such question exists or is it
more about the assumption on the
intervention distribution that's the
problem no okay good great question so
so i i didn't give you the positive
story obviously uh this morning so uh i
think i i obviously don't think uh the
goal is impossible because otherwise
that would spell bad news for the life
sciences or any sort of higher order
causal claim that we might make in
economics in psychology in biology uh
anything like that
so uh i i think the approach is starting
from wrong assumptions um
in in this framework i don't think it's
only the maximum entropy
distribution that is the problem
in some sense the moment i see a maximum
entropy distribution go into anything
the alarm bells go off for me because i
think that's a very very specific
setting that you're then using and
you're fixing things in a very uh um
you're pretending to to do it without
any sort of background or or
putting in any information but in fact i
think you're fixing the system in an
enormous way
so that is one problem in this this
model but i think the other problem is
actually uh the notion of the
intervention on the macro variable being
a sum of the uh
intervention effects of the micro level
values that map to that macro level
value so and there uh eric cole uses
uses just a again a uniform distribution
but it doesn't really matter to me what
the distribution is there i think in all
cases that's a bad idea when i set the
temperature in this room to 80
fahrenheit i'm setting it to a specific
microscopic state value right i might
not know which one it is but i'm setting
it to a specific one i'm not setting it
to an average of a whole bunch of values
so i think this sort of question of how
do we instantiate the macro level
intervention at the micro level how do
we understand this sort of choice of a
micro level distribution that is picked
given the macro level setting is one
that we need to think about very
carefully and i think that has been
glossed over in this this account and
it's nothing to do with maximum entropy
so
that's why ultimately i think we have to
think about using the conditional
distribution so of the effect given the
intervention on
given the intervention on the cause to
look at those to start course mean and
to do it perhaps in that space and so i
have a story to tell on that one that so
that i don't think is
you know there are other approaches that
also do that and
those i think are very interesting and
don't fall into these sorts of traps
oh i'm sorry uh currently can i quickly
interrupt
so i forgot to mention right now okay uh
it's just two sentences uh regarding
previous and i mentioned the situation
where the latent variable has uh have
changed correlations in this case you
cannot use independence based method in
addition even if the column model over
the latent variable and the measure
variable is fixed
very often times
we have to recover these two variables
because they are simpler again we cannot
just assume latent variable always
independent so
thank you very much
thanks
so another question for frederick
um see so i found your criticisms
convincing but i have a very basic
question about the setting which is
uh
what exactly is the the problem that
these meta these macro variables are
meant to solve
i guess like from a say a decision
theoretic perspective i would maybe
expect
there'd be some sort of criterion
they're going to use in some way i can
introduce the utility and then i can ask
hey what are the best
macro variables to introduce that'd be
like maybe my naive approach to it
maybe i just don't know the context and
literature but maybe you can fill me in
like what is the problem being solved
well one thing
just in
uh
as a slogan we are if you don't think
that there is some sort of macro
variable representation that we should
be learning then we should all be doing
quantum mechanics right so in some sense
it's a justification of looking at
higher order sciences as
an independent source independently
that higher order sciences can study
causal relations in their own right at
their level right at their level of
aggregation without having to worry
about what exactly the micro level
instantiation is so there's a question
in the sense about reductionism in the
sciences so whether we can build that
sort of thing
your your point about
well shouldn't we just put in some
utilities about what sort of thing i
want to uh you know affect and then um
given those utilities uh and and the
outcomes like i can get i uh should
aggregate according to those maybe maybe
that's the approach i think that's a
possibility but that presumes two things
one is that it is indeed possible to
arbitrarily aggregate just on the basis
of some sort of utility and i think
there's an alternative view where you
might say look what we're engaged in in
the sciences is to give some objective
description of what the world is like
that is independent of what exactly my
own utilities are
and
then the question is can we describe can
we provide such an objective description
of the world
given that some sort of aggregation
procedure and i think it's a legitimate
view to say that no
any sort of macro level description any
causal model in economics is ultimately
just about the utilities and things that
we're interested in
i think there's an alternative to say
that no there are objective facts to the
matter of whether inequality
is caused by some particular
inflation say
or whether that those are not objective
causal quantities never mind what your
utilities are about those
so
that's that's the goal is to somehow
provide some independent justification
about
causal claims at higher level sciences
obviously the model was extraordinarily
simplified never mind that
this is
this on
um so this is building on actually the
previous question which is also how does
this work in the reverse direction so in
a lot of these applications you have
this situation where
you don't really get to choose that
constitutive relation you just have some
data on some macro level thing
and
is there any way without being able to
observe the micro um data
to have a sense of
sort of um
how
uh strong your well i mean you you
mentioned there are several problems
with this um
with
how the paper did it but assuming that
you had something that worked really
nicely would there be some sort of
approach to kind of estimate how strong
your macro data it's causal
relationships yeah i think i think this
is a great question so i i think if we
can give a coherent story of this sort
of aggregation
then we might be able to tell
that the data that we've collected is at
the wrong level of granularity right
that it's too coarse already so now the
question is what are the indicators that
my data uh that my level of measurement
and my level of representation is
actually too coarse in that i should be
refining i think that's the kind of
question you're asking you're saying
like look going bottom up seems easy you
know i don't we don't hear a positive
story today but you know maybe there is
one but what about going the other way
right and i think that's that's in order
to tell what sort of errors or in or or
problems um we should be searching for
in our data to then say no we need to
refine uh our measurement we need to
have a coherent story of how we think
the whole system aggregates right and so
um i think that's a big open problem i
think we have anecdotal cases of
actually there's some reason to think
that the total cholesterol case that we
now think of hdl and ldl as important
constituents is something that people
saw these sorts of ambiguous
distributions in the effects of total
cholesterol you and your lab did your
total cholesterol experiment i did mine
in my lab and then there were different
resultant distributions in the effect
why because maybe we had different
levels of hdl versus ldl right and so
that gives an indication that we should
refine now i think the kinds of
indicators are not well understood yet
but i that would be nice to know so i i
do consider that part of the goal of
this sort of research project yeah
so this is definitely a discussion that
can continue over lunch maybe just also
for the virtual speaker so let's do just
another couple two minutes and so and
then we should end it um so you know i
want to just connect it by uri's talk
and elia's talk um so uri you had your
if i understood it correctly right the
action space was all discrete
now of course often you have say a drug
and a dose of a drug is in a in a you
know continuous space and also if we go
even a step further um for what elias
presented on soft interventions
what about if we actually do take these
actions to be soft interventions that
could for example be stochastic as ideas
have presented
how would you go about actually adding
you know being actions being an
intervention being something causal um
maybe you have to take a model based rl
setting or how would you actually
integrate that
i mean there was a question for elias as
well
um
yeah that's a great question we're
actually we're working now on on
continuous interventions but in a
simpler setting not not in a
reinforcement learning setting
um
yeah and it's hard uh
you have to make some some extra
assumptions
for this to work you need some model or
some continuity or something
uh
about soft intervention so actually
there's there's these couple of results
about like stochastic policies that
they're
sometimes you don't sometimes the
optimal policy you know is deterministic
right there's a bunch of classic results
in rl which i'm not actually i'm not
kind of fully i don't remember the
details that say sometimes you don't
have to consider uh
stochastic interventions
however if we're talking about rl online
with continuous actions
uh yeah that that seems uh hard uh
though i have to say even the robot we
did the action space was essentially
continuous right you have like these
joints but there's just all these
methods people develop like very applied
like how to discretize it to make this
actually work in practice
i have to say this is
stuff i like
guy the phd students he he knows this
stuff much better than me how to make it
work in practice
uh he also knows the theory but uh
yeah our theory for example for bandits
with continuous actions i don't know
what's a theory even just for online i i
wonder if if other people here know like
for continuous actions just in standard
contextual bandits that seems like a
hard problem to me and i don't know
what's kind of what results exist maybe
someone here on the panel or in the
crowd would know better than i did
i think we're nearly up ideas do you
want to add something and then this will
be the last word
i would just i'm not sure if
once you end in this note but yeah
continuous is very very tough uh
if if it's continuous outcome uh i think
we can do almost
not assumption-free but quite mild kind
of set of assanges
if his continuous actions i'm not sure
i'm not familiar with results of this
kind but what he said is a little bit of
a maybe a hack but we're kind of
discretized but it may it may make sense
uh uh given that you're anyhow in some
settings may it may make sense um uh to
have it fully not quote unquote
non-parametric i think most of the
results that we're discussing i think
uri as well it's kind of leveraging or
some type of bounding of the
distributions that you use from the
offline data and incorporating the
online data then
to be honest in the last one year maybe
is the one that you are learning the
results for the discrete case it took
maybe 20 or 25 years since the first
result by bulky and pro or or even
before
uh in econometrics by monsky
and uh then continues i think is still
work to be done perhaps for the folks
where the time the simon's they can help
us with these questions
great so i think with this thank you all
so much i think it's great to
end with open questions um for us to all
work on and directions to actually take
on so with this um we'll end the panel
discussion here we have a break until 2
30
um so we'll all be back here at 2 30 and
then we'll have two more talks and again
a panel discussion
so see you all back in the afternoon and
have a great lunch um you know there are
people here who are local you can follow
them around
to find the launch place to go to
thank you
thank you caroline thank you analysts
for wonderful talks